i
[Música]
la fiscalía ucraniana anunció el primer
caso contra un soldado ruso por un
presunto crimen de guerra esto esto
mientras kiev intenta intercambiar
prisioneros para salvar a militares de
la planta de as of salem mariupol y las
fuerzas ucranianas hacen un contragolpe
en la región de jarquín tenemos informes
desde uno de los pueblos retomamos
fracaso en el senado estadounidense un
proyecto de ley para convertir el
derecho al aborto en norma federal los
50 republicanos y un demócrata se
opusieron al texto mientras crecen los
temores de que la corte suprema pueda
revocar la sentencia del roe versus way
en cisjordania mataron a una periodista
veterana que trabajaba para el medio al
yazira colegas que estaban con sabina o
aquel sostienen que los militares
israelíes le dispararon mientras que
israel lo niega y propone hacer parte de
la investigación del caso
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
placer estar con ustedes y empezamos con
la actualidad de ucrania porque allí se
realizará el primer juicio por crímenes
de guerra desde que rusia invadió al
país la principal fiscal ucraniana
detalló que su oficina acusó al sargento
badín cheech marin por supuestamente
haberle disparado a un civil de 62 años
en una aldea en el noreste del país la
fiscalía añadió que está investigando
más de 10.700 presuntos crímenes de
guerra cometidos por rusia el caso se
conoce cuando kiev reveló que están
negociando con moscú para intercambiar
militares ucranianos que están heridos
en la planta de as of talent mariupol y
cambiarlos por prisioneros de guerra
rusos
otra de las novedades de este día 77 de
la guerra es una contraofensiva que
realizaron las tropas ucranianas en la
región dejar que las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas que están en el área
sostienen que recuperaron cuatro aldeas
en el norte y en el noreste una de las
zonas ya recuperadas es el pueblo de
malaya arrojan muestras enviadas irene
savio y leticia álvarez fueron hasta
allí veamos
estamos en malaya arrojando por dos
meses las tropas rusas ocuparon y
atacaron este pueblo del sur de jarquín
en su asedio a esta importante ciudad la
población local incluso vio los
barracones donde se resguardaban hasta
que el ejército ucraniano retomó el
control de la aldea
la talla pasó semanas en este sótano
mientras las tropas rusas se encontraban
en el pueblo
qué tal si salíamos a buscar ayuda
humanitaria corríamos el riesgo de que
nos matarán podía ver a los
francotiradores desde la entrada de la
puerta de mi casa tres hombres fueron
asesinados así un hombre caminaba con su
hijo de cuatro años y también lo mataron
hay helicópteros abatidos hospitales
acribillados automóviles incendiados es
el paisaje de esta aldea los restos de
los combates se ven en todas partes no
queda prácticamente nadie en este pueblo
sólo las personas que resistieron a la
ocupación rusa y la artillería sigue
retumbando en roban otra aldea cercana
badín por jacques tiembla al hablar del
desamparo que sintió
no entiendo aquí no hay objetivos
militares solo muchas casas en las que
viven personas no entiendo nuestra gente
vivía en paz
desde bootloader
valentina es otra superviviente nos
muestra el salón de su casa no queda
nada intacto
todavía estamos en shock y tenemos miedo
cuando oímos un ruido nos escondemos
enseguida cortan la guerra aún está
cerca de estas aldeas el ejército
ucraniano y ruso batallan por pocos
metros de tierra en un conflicto de
desgaste de final incierto
vamos a eeuu el senado bloqueó el
proyecto con el que buscaba que el
derecho al aborto se convirtiera en ley
federal la llamada ley de protección de
la salud de la mujer sólo contó con 49
de los 60 votos necesarios para su
aprobación todos los 50 republicanos se
opusieron y a ellos se unió el senador
demócrata joe manchin
esta votación apresurada impulsada por
el partido demócrata
medio de los temores de que la corte
suprema de justicia pueda revocar john
roberts white que garantiza la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
desde 1973 tras la filtración de un
borrador de la opinión de la mayoría de
los magistrados lo que esa es su
intención
esto ya nos ha decepcionado estoy aquí
para decirle que lo que vimos hoy es que
los republicanos se dicen a todos los
estadounidenses y a las mujeres en
particular que su voz es más importante
que la del día
después mismo que lo que creen es más
importante que la elección sobre tu
propio cuerpo tu propia familia y tu
propio futuro les digo a las mujeres de
todo eeuu como yo y muchas otras
que ahora no es el momento de echarse
atrás o sentarse ahora es el momento de
alzar nuestras voces y contraatacar
por voices and faith
pasamos a noticias de américa latina el
ministro del interior paraguayo federico
gonzález señaló este miércoles que el
fiscal marcelo pecci que investigaba
crímenes de narcotráfico era el objetivo
del ataque en que acabó con su vida en
colombia recordemos que pepsi disfrutaba
de su luna de miel en la isla colombiana
de barú cuando alguien le disparó en
plena playa y acabó con su vida decía
todo federico gonzález aseguró que están
analizando más alternativas cuando todo
es lamentable ellos pero condenamos y
sentimos muchísimo es algo que se está
investigando él llegó con su señora a
colombia en un viaje privado una vez
como estamos al tanto y sucedió esto
entendemos que era el objetivo pero se
están analizando varias alternativas a
sus cursos de acción en temas la
periodista silvina buback la
corresponsal palestina estadounidense
del medio al yazira fue asesinada de
cisjordania los hechos ocurrieron
mientras informaba en la ciudad de jenín
y vestía un chaleco que claramente decía
prensa varios reporteros que estaban en
el lugar afirman que los militares
israelíes son responsables mientras que
israel dice que es pronto para saber de
dónde vino el fuego y propone una
investigación gabriel coll chen nos
cuenta las reacciones el asesinato de
shireen agua que le dejó al mundo árabe
conmocionado en ramala miles de personas
participaron en la procesión del cuerpo
de la periodista allí manifestaron su
tristeza e indignación por el crimen hay
un agua que le eche en su analista
shireen abu a que era una periodista muy
buena es conocida en todo el mundo árabe
por lo que estoy muy triste porque es
una pérdida para todos los periodistas
árabes palestinos americanos para todo
el mundo apple está yendo américa a
telemundo alianza moody otro periodista
presente durante el ataque y que resultó
herido nadu desde el hospital como
fueron los hechos en los que la
comunicadora perdió la vida que la
ocupación es asesina y criminal nos
dispararon sin razón alguna nosotros un
grupo de periodistas estábamos allí con
nuestro uniforme de prensa completo
además de los cascos con la palabra
press escrita en letras grandes y de
color en doha los trabajadores de al
yazira rindieron homenaje al trabajo de
la periodista y destacaron la
importancia de seguir informando desde
cisjordania
tenemos otros periodistas valientes que
seguirán cubriendo lo que pasa en el
terreno hace que giren estaría encantada
de que sigan trabajando esto no les
parará no dejará de dar voz a los que no
tienen
varios periodistas también se reunieron
en túnez enfrente de la sede del
sindicato nacional de periodistas
sabemos bien que la martín chirino era
una periodista normal sino que
denunciaba los crímenes sionistas y
todas sus prácticas racistas los
asesinatos la revolución la colonización
y los encarcelamientos siren era también
una militante que defendía la causa de
su patria el asesinato fue denunciado
como un ataque de los soldados israelíes
dirigido hacia la periodista pero israel
espera pruebas de una investigación para
pronunciarse
ence y blanca del presidente gotabaya
rajapaksa dijo que nombrar a un nuevo
gabinete luego de la dimisión de su
hermano y primer ministro en medio de
protestas generalizadas en el país por
la crisis económica y el alza del precio
de combustibles y alimentos raya baja
afirmó también que introducirá enmiendas
constitucionales para darle mayor poder
al parlamento promulgará de nuevo el
artículo 19 de la constitución que él
mismo derogó y que restringe el exceso
de poder presidencial
mientras trabajo para garantizar la
seguridad del país trabajaré con todos
los líderes de los partidos para lograr
la estabilidad política en el país estoy
tomando medidas para formar un nuevo
gobierno para controlar la situación
actual para evitar que el país caiga en
la anarquía y para mantener los asuntos
del gobierno que se han paralizado
20 viene factura a la negra
y terminamos con la famosa marioneta la
pequeña ha mal un símbolo internacional
de los niños refugiados
el personaje visitó una zona en la
ciudad de lviv al oeste de ucrania un
punto clave dentro del territorio
ucraniano para quienes huyen de la
guerra a male encarna una pequeña de
nueve años procedente de siria que busca
a su madre y representa a los menores
desplazados por la guerra
así nos despedimos ustedes sigan con más
en france 24
[Música]